hey there I'm Mari I mean he I'm
Courtney we're some of the people that
make up Smosh and today we're doing the
wired autocomplete interview
[Music]
what is Smosh doing right now we're
doing this our most viewed video was the
beef and go video it was a video that
featured a tube of meat that you could
take on the go and eat on the go but the
reason it got the most views is because
there was a very inappropriate thing
that was in the thumbnail was a complete
accident but it was a very inappropriate
image that I won't say what it was and I
think it's since been changed yeah but
also it's impossible to find the video
because YouTube buried it
what is the Smosh logo oh that's
something Anthony designed before we
even started making videos and it's just
two arrows like moving forward with like
an S in between and it just it just kind
of stand yeah you didn't know that no I
did not know that
what no I quickly but like I always
thought it was cute because it's like
not a like it's not perfectly designed
it's almost like there's a little flaw
in it you crapping on Anthony's designs
yeah it's just like it's very like a
wholesome he did make it in like high
school next one does Ian Hecox own Smosh
who at one point I did but being the
business boy that I was I was like oh
let's let's sell Smosh and try to make
it into something bigger than than just
two guys so technically no I don't own
Smosh when was born oh well the company
- yeah the website was was 2002 channels
-
five five five sixty nine six no no its
nine one one no that's worse no that's a
weird question to ask don't ask that
question if we don't give you our phone
number don't go looking for it that's
not nice
also don't call text first yeah yeah
yeah
does Smosh swear yeah yeah Smosh has
always been kind of seen as like we
always want to keep things like pg-13 so
we swear but anything that's like worse
than what you would see maybe on TV we
always bleep out but we've never really
been afraid to just where it's like yeah
whatever you're feeling just just throw
it out there and we can censor later if
we feel like it yeah they didn't invite
me back for the second one thanks guys
I was going to Community College didn't
know what I wanted to do I worked to
check the cheese when Smosh was getting
started I was Chucky so if you were
kicking Chucky Cheese at the Chuck E
Cheese over in Sacramento in the leg in
around the year of 2005 that was my leg
luckily Smosh work to help what is it
what is Eva's human human man does not
have superpowers yet who did Ian Hecox
oh go bang today's Angry Birds
Wow just rub it in
yeah he was bubbles oh yeah he's the
bird that gets like big and I was I was
like really excited when they announced
the second one you could you know just
said I'm just sitting there by the phone
just waiting for that phone call what
happened in I get it I ask this one
question myself once you cut that all
cut off they're like poof where you go
oh yeah maybe maybe when I cut off my my
bowl haircut which was like two years
too late and and like making the
decision to cut it
I got noticed like way less after that
point all right here we go
where does ian hecox creepy I live in
beautiful Los Angeles and I will not
elaborate on that question is in he
related to Abraham Lincoln the
world needs to know I don't even know
where that question
that's an Abraham Lincoln beard I've
asked this question on Google like 18
times and there is no definitive answer
yeah sure no where is where is she where
in the world is mari takahashi
that's so weird why is that the first
question what is what where who is and
what is I don't know I guess I travel a
lot too so when I'm in LA it's rare but
otherwise I'm here mari takahashi okay
there's a string of videos on on Smosh
in order where I have an eyepatch
because I scratched my eye that morning
and I didn't know what else to do so I
got an eyepatch at CBS favorite letter a
bandage one hmm it will look more like a
pirate eye patch looks like a pirate one
I
know many different kinds of eye patches
at least it wasn't pinkeye it wasn't
pinkeye it wasn't it wasn't pinkeye it's
probably pinkeye Amar'e talkie chips - I
was there for that wide open but no I
think I look cute with the chip tooth on
I would like girl Jim Carrey from Dumb
and Dumber is what I think I look like
quick background story we're on the
Queen Mary a ghost ship we were told
that it was a haunted ship I thought it
was complete BS so we're messing around
and we decided to have a piggyback ride
in which yeah it was a race piggyback
ride race I slip out of nowhere it came
out of nowhere I swear to god this is
when I was like okay ghost you've got it
yeah I chipped my tooth
all this was gone it was about half gone
you should have had that and the
eyepatch that would have been did mari
takahashi when you made it pretty far
right oh no I was second out and I'm
still salty about it hi guys I'm just so
hot like I got a hot flash thank you
marry Takahashi Wow
all time okay I'll give you two one is
done is better than perfect because you
know what we can't we can't strive for
perfection you just gotta do what you
can and you just gotta you got to do it
and then the other one is my quote which
I like to say which is show up and don't
be an ass definitely doing the right
okay if he says what he says it that's
fine
oh he can have it then Mario Hoshi gosh
I actually have zero tattoo right here
we all have zero oh my good oh my god
but one now also your parents with
murder you my dad would for sure disown
me because tattoos and my culture
Japanese culture is tied with Yakuza and
he's still very old-school about that
stuff and I also feel like I'm like if I
get one little tiny tattoo like on my
arm like I would end up with a full
sleeve
because you're an overachiever I think
I'm a completionist who is destined to
make you laugh uncomfortably next time
what really is Courtney Miller no that's
it what breed is what breed is pretty
mother's dog my mom right now but Jango
the cutest little pup ever he's a
Vietnamese Ridgeback and it's a rare and
kind of newer breed didn't get
recognized by the AKC until last year
and it's he's incredible I have like a
ridge on their back and they're like
really that makes sense these originals
bags sever he actually was born without
a ridge on his back so how tall is
Courtney Miller's dog please a big dog
how tall are your feet oh I don't know
I'm five six I think like on the dot
maybe even just below is Courtney Miller
vegan I was for eight months early on in
the career yeah give it the old college
try
oh gosh I was really bored with my life
also wanted to see like how it would
help because I like skin issues so I'm
gonna like want to see if it helped it
really affect my skin but I lost it like
all my baby fat which was crazy hmm
yeah not vegan anymore I love chili is
Courtney Miller in glee
what I get that sometimes I'm I look
like the girl Brittany from who put the
girl who plays Brittany from Glee I
forget the actresses name when I wasn't
on vine everyone thought that I look
like Britney from Glee don't really get
that as much anymore I don't see it at
all it is Courtney Miller left-handed
yes Oh as proven by the snap oh damn B
snap yepper
Oh Ecklie I'm actually i'ma dextrous
because I do all my writing and like
little intricate stuff but then all my
athletic stuff like throwing and when I
was pull welting and like eating
right-handed so myself yeah eating is
super hot water for me yeah
who owns this is true
previously Smosh is owned by this
company called defy media maybe you've
heard about them some not great things
happened and they cannot business and
Smosh was rescued by mythical
entertainment who if you guys don't know
who that is that's rhett and Link who
are also some YouTube
oh geez they came to our rescue and
things couldn't be better
yeah we recently did a YouTube viewer he
like took fan made Smosh quizzes and one
of them was a quizzing who's your Smosh
boyfriend cuz you got Noah right and
then they make no Keith and I got Shane
I wonder how my boyfriend would be who
do you think would be your perfect would
be your you know no TV I'm gonna say
lasercorn because I think that it would
just be like this constant like fighting
rivalry and then we'll have little
moments of like oh that was a nice bin I
said and then we'll just like fight
again who is in Smosh games well that's
that's kind of a hard question ask now
because now smosh smosh games smoshgames
was kind of separate from Smosh and
we're like why we're all friends why are
we why are we two separate things
now we're an amoeba yeah what is the
definition of the word Smosh that goes
way back to the the 2002 when one of my
friends said Smosh put inside a mosh pit
and it became an inside joke between
myself Antony and the rest of our
friends and then Anthony created a
website we were like what we call it
I'll call it Smosh and then we called
that Smosh and then when we started
making videos we're like I would call
our videos I don't know
Smosh so Smosh is kind of it just kind
of stuck well that's it thank you for
asking all these questions about
maybe less personal ones don't ask where
we live well thank you guys bye
[Music]